[Music]
welcome to everyone uh who's here in the
room and to to the folks uh who are uh
on Zoom I'm John Lan I'm the dean of the
Stanford Graduate School business and
it's a pleasure to kick off this event
on uh on AI and democracy um I want to
say this is an event that is
co-sponsored by the Stanford Business
School uh our business government
Society initiative and the Harris School
of public policy at Chicago and I
actually could not think of a better or
more important topic to be co-organized
by uh by a business school and a public
policy school right now than the
intersection of of artificial
intelligence and uh our Democratic
processes um both because um this is one
of those areas where um private sector
Innovation and the proliferation of
technology is is coming up against
sometimes in productive ways and
sometimes in unproductive ways our
Democratic processes and electoral
processes and also because this is an
area where uh the public and the private
sector really do need to work together
so that we can ensure stable uh
institutions for the for the future um
so I'm going to introduce uh the two
organizers of this event um uh who then
will kick things off uh the NY Hall is
the D family professor of political
economy at The Graduate School of
Business also in the department of
political science at Stanford he is the
co-director of the democracy and
polarization lab uh senior fellow at
Seer um and um is one of the uh co-leads
of our business and beneficial
technology uh pillar of the business
government Society initiative Ethan
Bueno deusa is the uh Sydney Stein
professor at the University of Chicago
Harris School of public poliy and for
the moment um has been drafted into the
role also of interim dean of the Harris
School so um my sympathies uh to you
Ethan for uh for taking on that role but
it's it's great that you did it and and
everyone seem I've heard from just
thinks you're great and maybe you'll get
stuck in that job so um uh anyway
welcome to everyone welcome to everyone
on zoom and uh over to Andy and
Ethan it's great to see people here uh
said uh this was a joint of the Harris
School and uh the Stanford Business
School and the basic idea I guess we
want to just give you a a few minutes on
sort of what we think we've learned and
where we are and then we're going to
talk a little bit and take some
questions but we want to give you a
brief overview of sort of how we how
we're thinking and and what we're up to
here um so let me just say a word about
sort of what what we actually did um it
was it was our view that sort of AI
generally obviously is kind of a big
part of the policy conversation and the
political conversation going on in the
United States and around the world and
we decided it would be a good thing for
a policy school and a business school to
try and team up and think through some
of the thorny issues provide some uh I
don't know analysis some intellectual
guidance to try and help the
conversation be as productive as
possible um and we thought the natural
first place to start was thinking about
Ai and elections in part because I guess
Andy and I are both political scientists
so politics seems like the most
important thing but also it feels urgent
uh we're coming up on the 2024 elections
and it feels like if we're going to make
some progress if the conversation uh
around policy around civil society
around self-regulation by industry is
going to going to get us somewhere it
has to get us somewhere pretty soon um
if it's going to if it's going to help
us run a a a fair and free and
successful election in 2024 so we
thought the place to start was on
elections and it seemed uh natural to
try and do this uh you know an
institution that's inside Silicon Valley
an institution that's outside of Silicon
Valley an institution that's focused on
the industry side and an institution
that's focused on the policy side seemed
like a natural complimentarity and so it
seemed like a good opportunity for an
academic partnership to work on these
issues and so what we actually did was
we got together a group of academics um
as well as some folks from industry we
had people come from all of the big AI
companies from from Google from meta
from open AI from Tik Tok uh from
Microsoft and some folks from Civil
Society we had a we spent a day together
um I won't give you any quotes because
we we we did it under um under chatam
house rule but um but we talked very
frankly about sort of how the people
from from industry were thinking about
what are the risks what are the
opportunities what are the issues what
are they working on what's
technologically feasible what's not and
the academics uh spent a lot of time
asking them hard questions and so part
of our goal was to sort of take
academics who know a lot about the law
about politics about regulation and get
them up to speed on the technology and
then let them ask hard analytical
questions so that we could sort of paint
a picture of the landscape and get a
real clear sense of of where we are and
whether things are are bad or good and
if they're bad what what what we do
about it and I think our main goal being
academics is not to get straight to
policy recommendations so we're
releasing a white paper today or we've
released a white paper today and it does
offer some some ideas about things that
various actors tech companies government
journalists Civil Society might take to
try and help um make the elections run
smoothly but but our main goal was not
to get straight to policy
recommendations but rather to sort of
provide some analysis and Clarity on
what the risks and what the
opportunities are in the hopes of
helping Society in general have a more
productive conversation and get to ideas
about policy interventions as we go
forward in the coming months so what
we're going to spend most of our time on
today and what we spend most of our time
on in the white paper is not really
tight policy recommendations we don't
think there's easy solutions but rather
trying to paint a clear an analytic
picture of the landscape and the set of
problems as we can to try and help us
all have a more productive conversation
I hope we can do some of that um today
so let me get to just like a quick
overview of a couple of the things and
Andy will talk about a couple of the
things we talked about um and then we'll
get into a
conversation okay so I think all of us I
think came to believe through the course
of these conversations and many of you
may already believe this from from
various press coverage you've seen that
the number one issue that we need to be
thinking about when we think about the
ways in which AI is going to matter for
elections is the ways in which it poses
risks of degrading the information
environment faced by voters and I think
the most obvious version of that risk is
the Deep fake October surprise okay so
the Deep fake October surprise is the
super convincing video the super
convincing picture of something
scandalous of something uh politically
damaging that a campaign that an
interest group that a political party
that some other nefarious actor puts out
against one about one of their political
opponents and we talk about the October
surprise because I think the biggest
worry of course this could happen
anytime during the campaign the biggest
worry we think is that such a thing gets
released it gets released widely on
social media or in traditional media
very close to the election when there is
not enough time for responsible actors
to figure out what's true and what's
false and to help voters sort through
that information okay so I think that's
that's a genuine risk AI can create
genuinely convincing videos it can
create Ely pred uh convincing
photographs which are entirely false uh
now it's not the case that that's
something completely new Under The Sun
It's always you know for a long time
it's been possible to create doctored
photos to create edited videos which
were misleading so it's not sort of
something we've never faced before but
the the capacity for realism the
capacity for scale and the ability to do
it kind of on demand in in tailored ways
is quite worrying um we think there's
real risk that voters might in fact be
faced with you know in the week before
the
election material that would might
affect their votes that they're going to
have to figure out um if they believe it
or not and it's going to be hard for
them so that that's a genuine concern
there's another level of insidiousness
to the Deep fake problem Beyond just the
October surprise and I think the deeper
level of insidiousness is this idea of
the information environment so we've
already seen in some elections some deep
fake material come out so we saw this in
the Turkish elections where a candidate
was shown in a fake video with a leader
the pkk you probably maybe many of you
saw recently reporting on the Argentine
election where these were not I think
the argentin case not really videos
meant to or pictures meant to deceive
they were obviously fabricated but they
were genuinely fabricated putting your
political opponent in a situation they
were never in the same has been true uh
in the US primaries where for example we
had sort of a a famous ad by the RNC of
uh President Biden and vice president
Harris in kind of a dystopian future
that wasn't misleading like nobody
thought that that dystopian future was
real but it it it was on the slippery
slope towards it right so that's one
version of it but the next thing that
happens is when voters can't be sure
whether video or picture images that
they see online or real are fake not
only do they not know how to evaluate
whether something's real or fake but it
provides a tool for
candidates for whom real information
that's damaging comes out to deny it
that is it breaks down our whole sense
of whether we can trust kind of the
evidence of our senses or at least the
evidence of our digital senses right and
so we saw in the Turkish election that a
as far as we can tell real scandalous
video came out against about one
candidate and his immediate response to
it was that's a deep fake right so it's
not just that deep fakes come out but
real information comes out and voters
don't know it's real or false okay so
there's a real degrading of the
information environment and I think the
most Pat Solutions we've seen talked
about things like watermarking digital
materials things like social media
organizations labeling those materials
one of the things I think we learned
quite convincingly from the tech side is
that stuff's not going to work nearly so
well as you might have hoped and that's
true for two reasons one it's super easy
to get around that those those
techniques it's just we just don't have
a kind of foolproof way of water marking
and labeling that nefarious actors can't
get around that's one side the other
side is it's over inclusive so as it
turns out kind of everything is touched
by AI now if you want to do red eyee
reduction you're going to use AI if you
want to you remove an extraneous person
from the background of a picture you're
going to use Ai and so if we start
watermarking and labeling everything
that's been touched by AI suddenly
everything would be labeled and now the
labels don't mean anything and if we
don't want to do that we want to say no
no we mean you know label the things
that are like really generated by AI
we're just back in the gray area where
tech companies or media Outlets or
social media companies or whatever are
making constant sort of calls in the
gray area between what's a nefarious use
or an illegitimate use or not and that
puts us back in in this world of kind of
content moderation Wars that we've seen
for the last couple uh presidential
elections so there's no easy solutions
but there are real problems for the
information
environment the other the other I'll
just say quickly the other piece of the
information environment that that came
up and that we talk about in the white
paper is this kind of seeking technical
factual information about election
Administration from chat Bots and the
like so that is one of the things that
folks are worried about is that voters
will go on chat GPT and say hey where do
I register to vote here's my ZIP code or
where's my ping place and your AI chat
plot's not an appropriate tool for that
it doesn't know the answer to that
question uh and it might there's a risk
that it would make up an answer the
question it turns out Harris just did a
a poll with the AP and uh norc if you
ask Americans what they think they might
use AI for in elections that's the thing
they say they might use AI for and
that's pretty worrying because it's
really not the appropriate tool now the
tech companies are all kind of training
their chat Bots to not answer that
question right if you ask chat gbt today
you know I live in 94305 five where do I
vote uh what will say to you is
something like um I'm not an appropriate
tool for answering that question you
should go check your secretary of
state's website which is great we just
want to put out there that this is sort
of another piece of the information
environment to think
about a second thing we talked about and
I think the other main concern you hear
in the public discourse about this stuff
is about sort of microt targeting and
the use of AI to create manipulative
highly specialized materials at scale
okay materials that's going to like you
know AB test against every voter until
we figure out just the thing to get them
and we'll talk about this a lot more as
we as we have our conversation but we
want to be deflationary about this we
think the Deep fakes information
environment problem is really the one to
focus on and this kind of microt
targeting and manipulation problem is
probably a bit overblown and I'm going
to let others talk more about that about
why we think that but we think there's a
good evidentiary basis inside social
science on elections to say it's
unlikely this is going to be super
effective I'm going turn over to
Andy
Ethan really I think did a really good
job of covering the things we're most
concerned about and I think as deep fake
October surprise that's like the phrase
I'm keeping in my head that's like the
number one thing we want to focus on we
also spent quite a bit of time though
talking about opportunities I think it's
very understandable to be focused on the
threats of a new technology and and
people are right to be thinking about
that now before the election but there
are also really interesting
opportunities for this new technology in
the political space and we wanted to
spend some time talking about that um as
well and so we know that one of the big
challenges right in democracies is
making sure that people uh have access
to useful information about candidates
about politicians about what's going on
in the world and we know that's
challenging for a number of reasons most
of which have to do with people's level
of Interest or level of Engagement with
the information that they're provided
with today and I think there's like
pretty interesting evidence that these
new AI generated sort of chat Bots are
actually a potentially very engaging way
for people to access
um synthesis you know syntheses of large
amounts of complex information and that
that could be used for voters in pretty
cool way so uh we have one of the
co-authors on the white paper yil valz
actually has some ongoing research on
this where he takes in a bunch of party
platforms and information about party's
positions and puts it into a special
customized chatbot that you can then
talk to and you can ask it questions
about like you know I care about the
following issue can you tell me about in
my state or my locality like the
positions of the parties or candidates
on that issue how should I think about
that and you can you can engage the bot
in a much deeper conversation um that I
think could turn out to be a really
interesting and valuable way um for
people to learn more about politics in a
less in a more accessible more
userfriendly less kind of intimidating
way so we're very interested to follow
you Mill's research on that as well as
other people we encourage others to to
think about studying that area because
we think it's pretty important um we'll
just note also Al and this is a point
that we can expand on perhaps with with
Greg Martin on the panel is uh we know
that down the ballot right campaigns and
candidates have a lot less resources and
it's harder for them to reach voters
it's harder for them to package up
information for voters and again these
tools may allow those down ballot
candidates to actually provide more
information in a more accessible way to
voters so at the and we've seen this
with previous Technologies there could
be we're not saying we're sure about
this is just a possibility it could be
that at the top of the ticket these
Technologies are quite disruptive in
ways we worry about whereas down the
ticket where information is already very
low it could actually be beneficial to
candidates and so we're interested to
see in let's say in the US and state and
local races are we going to find
positive ways that otherwise under
resource campaigns are able to use these
tools so really want to uh kind of
expand on that as well because we think
it's an important area um finally I'm
just going to talk about one bigger
picture concern that came up that's
probably longer and slower lower moving
than just the 2024 election but which we
think is also important for people to be
thinking about now and this is the risk
of what we call information
centralization so one of the things
we've seen over the last 10 years is
increasing concerns that these very
large online platforms because so much
of our social economic political and
cultural lives now take place on these
platforms the decisions that a social
media company or a search company makes
about sort of who's allowed to say what
what information is true or false and so
forth they have pretty big influences on
society and there's been a big debate in
the social media sphere and I've been
involved in this work about who are the
right actors to make those decisions
about that that really affect our
Collective ability to communicate with
one another about politics for example
it's possible we don't know what will
happen but it's possible that generative
AI is going to accelerate that challenge
in the sense that imagine a world in the
future where a lot of us are generating
a lot of our materials whether it's news
articles or political essays or speeches
or posts or whatever through these
generative AI tools and if they're
concentrated in a small number of large
platforms there's a potentially very
worrying dystopian future where what
ideas or values are expressed in society
comes under the influence of a set of
rules decided by a small set of
companies and that could really
accelerate the challenges we've already
seen in social media and we want to
highlight that because we think um
that's an important area for people to
start thinking about now well the actual
use of these tools is still relatively
Limited in society and we might want to
think about ways to govern these
generative AI platforms of the future um
to make those rules and those guard
rails sort of set by processes that
people think are fair uh and legitimate
okay that was a brief hopefully quick
but useful uh overview of our white
paper and now what we want to do is kind
of go beyond the particular topics we
raised in the white paper have a general
discussion of AI and democracy in the
2024 election with with our awesome
panel that we'll introduce um when we
get together uh up here and so we'll
turn to that now so if I could just ask
the panelist to join me so let's start
over here with Greg Greg Martin if
you'll give it a brief introduction uh
of yourself and here's the first
question I'd like you to answer um
you're a published expert on media and
democracy especially in the US and I it
would be great to just hear your
thoughts on what you're seeing with
respect to AI in the 2024 election how
you think it's going to affect overall
media environment uh and the course of
the election yeah sure so I'm Greg
Martin I'm a professor here at GSP in
the political economy group um I study
kind of media and advertising and
elections mostly in the US is kind of my
my focus um I think there's like a
couple of things to think about in terms
of what the effect of AI on the sort of
broader media environment might be in
the future um so one thing that I'm a
little bit concerned about is the
possibility that AI generated content
might be used as a substitute for actual
reporting right so you might think of
this as like an extension or an
acceleration of the trend that's already
been happening in the past couple of
decades where newspapers are kind of
substituting you know content from wire
services or syndicated content or doing
original reporting because it's it's
cheaper right so you can imagine and
actually I know that there are papers
doing this right now using AI to write
write articles and uh using that that
opportunity to sort of fire their actual
their actual reporters who are doing
real reporting so that's I think a real
uh worry ort of the quality of um
accountability at the local level might
be affect might be affected by that uh
another thing to to think about is sort
of just the centralizing you kind of
brought this up right the fact that AI
might kind of centralize the information
environment in in the sense of uh
coordinating everyone on using the same
everyone is using the same models like
everyone all of the uh all the different
papers might start to look the same
right and that might sort of hurt the um
uh I think one goal of a media
regulation is to sort of provide a
diverse set of voices and if everyone's
relying on the same models which are
trained on the same set of information
right that might degrade the sort of
quality of that uh that diversity um and
then last thing to think about is sort
of just the effects on on trust and
media sources so we um Ethan I think
already brought up the idea that the
possibility of deep fakes might degrade
Trust in Media sources if you can't you
can't tell what's real or not I think
there's another kind of more subtle
aspect of trust um so one one piece of
uh developing trust that's really
important is getting the sense that the
source like shares your world viiew or
your perspective right this is one
reason why partisan sources are so
popular right because you it's more
trustworthy to hear information from
someone you think is on your side and I
imagine it might be hard for readers to
like determine what is the political
position of an AI generated story right
or on the other hand it might be
possible for uh for someone who wants to
manipulate people to you know right
leftwing ideas and a right-wing tone or
something sort of confuse readers about
where where the source is coming from so
anyway those are kind of three things
that I've been thinking about
interesting can you how about on the
opportunity side do you see are there
flip sides to those issues where the
information like I was talking about
before can be used in effective valuable
ways what do you think how do you think
we can harness the good parts yeah so I
think like the capacity of U large
language models to summarize and
synthesize is actually really useful and
has a lot of potential so I think like
one thing that that parties do like the
function that they serve in a democracy
is to simplify things right most of us
are not like super familiar with
intimate workings of the of the
government and if you think about like
all the possible things that the United
States government could do that's kind
of an infinitely complicated uh set of
things right and so what parties do is
sort of put Focus attention on specific
issues they give reasons or principles
that like apply across across issues
right and they make analogies that make
complicated things easier to understand
right and all those things are things
that that AI can do right and it can do
it on a greater scale it can do it with
more personalization and so I think
there is a real potential for uh for
that for that type of use uh to bring
more people into the political process
and increase participation and make it
possible for more people to
participate thanks I hope we can expand
on that in the Q&A there's a lot there's
a lot to unpack there um chrisan if
you'll also introduce yourself as well
and if you can tell us I know you're an
expert on algorithmic bias and Trust um
and it would be great to hear from you
sort of what do you think are some of
the key issues in terms of bias for
generative Ai and how might they
manifest in relevant ways for the 2024
election yeah so hi I'm I'm Christian um
I'm a professor at the University of
Chicago in the data Science Institute um
I'm also one of the founders of the
fairness accountability and transparency
conference and soci Technical Systems
where people talk about those big three
key issues in essentially ml models um
and possibly relevant to this I was also
um one of the research leads for
Twitter's group that was doing machine
learning ethics transparency and
accountability until about last year and
so yeah did something happen did
something happen I don't know I assume
we all know what happened okay um and so
you know how can we think about
algorithmic bias in the context of
generative AI I think it it gets a
little bit tricky because when we've
thought about algorithmic bias in the
past and other cont context it's been
sort of in the context of a model that
does a specific thing like it predicts a
specific thing maybe it's predicting
whether someone will be rearrested um
that's one of the sort of common ways
people think about this and you think
about bias in that sense it's making it
say differently accurate for different
groups of people things like that when
we're talking about generative AI which
is a lot more general purpose people can
ask it to predict pretty much anything
right and so it it's a little bit hard
to know what those biases are going to
look like but we do have Frameworks to
think about this so maybe someone could
ask a model something like predict who
would be most aligned with a candidate
or or predict what's going to happen you
know in this location um so we have some
tools to think about it but we really
don't know the parameters under which
people are actually asking those
questions to do the evaluation to see if
the models are behaving in a way that's
biased or Fair Etc um we've also thought
a lot in that Community about things
like allocative unfairness so you know
when we're thinking about something like
Twitter how are we allocating
Impressions right how are we allocating
attention to different sorts of things
we could see that come up also so in
generative AI people might ask things
like you know share some good sources of
information about this issue and you
know there there could be concerns that
it's really skewing one way or the other
way it's not giving a really
representative picture it's sort of
allocating all the attention to only
certain facets of the issue that's
something else we might um sort of start
to think about and of course there's
also these sort of representational
issues so the really famous study in
this area or the famous observationist
area from a while back was when somebody
Googled CEO what was returned was a
whole bunch of of men and then the first
woman was CEO Barbie um and so these are
sort of representational issues right
sort of reifying existing stereotypes
that maybe are harmful and sort of to
speak to your comment and some of the
previous comments you can imagine this
idea of reifying existing stereotypes
could crop up if people are using the
models to write articles right you could
sort of have these sort of negative
stereotypes kind of very subtly make
their way into different articles um but
at the end of the day I think it's you
know it it it can be a little bit tricky
to assess these things things I think
it's um you know it's not going to be as
obvious that these things are happening
as it is for the sorts of uses that
we've been talking about with like
malicious use like intentionally
generating disinformation or
intentionally generating deep fakes I
think that's going to be really at the
Forefront of what's going on but these
sort of more subtle things that can sort
of creep in I think will play a role and
it's going to take a while for us to
sort out what all is happening with
those in terms of sorting it out I know
something you've thought about closely
related to these questions about bias is
sort of this TR this idea of
transparency people talk a lot about AI
transparency uh I think you have some
thoughts like what kinds of transparency
around generative AI do you think would
be most useful right so this really
piggybacks on what I was just saying you
know when people think about
transparency now it's a lot of
transparency about policies maybe
transparency about the model weights
right actually releasing the model I
think one of the most useful things for
us right now to really start doing the
types of evaluations we need to do to
understand what this these sort of
subtle biases are is information about
how people are actually using the model
I was really excited to hear about the
study you you just mentioned Ethan um
that that survey but I also think the
tech companies do have data on how
people are using their models and I
think it would be a really big step
towards giving the research community
and giving the public good information
about what sort of risks we should
anticipate what sort of biases we should
be looking for if they could tell us how
are people actually using these yeah I
completely agree I was telling you this
yesterday but I'm working on a project
that's about how do people feel about if
you have a different version of chat gbt
or another chatbot that has different
political views one of my co-authors is
in the back of the room nodding um and
one of the things that's challenging is
what we'd like to do is create these
more Republican or more democratic
versions of the tool and give it to
people and see how it affects their
views and things like that but to do
that in a compelling way we need to give
them tasks to do that would be
representative of the tasks people
actually are using these tools to do and
we have we really don't know we don't
know how they're using them today in the
real world and so we don't know how to
to line that up so that's definitely
something would be very valuable um
Emily grateful to have a political
philosopher on the panel as well uh
please yeah introduce yourself and and
we'd love to hear a little bit you've
you've done some work uh you wrote a
book pretty recently that encouraged
people to check out um on the importance
of like the practice of democracy as a
citizen um and the value for example of
us all coming together on Election Day
and participating in the shared ceremony
of voting and things like that and so I
think it would be really helpful to hear
from from you um how you think
generative AI could affect our ability
to have these sort of like shared
experiences and shared practice of
democracy yeah thanks so uh I'm Emily
Chapman I'm an assistant professor in
the political science department and
like Andy said I I'm a kind of political
theorist political philosopher so I
think about the kinds of values that our
political Institutions and practices uh
ody and and kind of how that should
inform our approaches to trying to make
them better um so I think we could can
really think about maybe the effect of
generative AI from from two different
directions so one focuses more on kind
of how does it affect candidates or or
sort of Representatives and the other is
how it affects voters and the the public
at large so in thinking about kind of
candidates and and representatives I
think the main kind of question that I
would have is how is this affecting the
process by which campaigns think about
trying to understand voters and um and
how that affects uh sort of the quality
of representation as well as the kind of
attitudes that uh candidates and
representatives have towards uh their
constituents or or potential
constituents so there's definitely an
ethical dimension of this where you know
as Democratic theorists we like to think
about uh political speech as being a
kind of two-way street where yes
campaigns kind of make try and make
persuasive arguments about like what the
major social problems are and what
government ought to do and try and uh
get win votes that way but they're also
sort of um in theory responsive to kind
of hearing citizens uh feedback uh to
that and so we'll we'll kind of need to
address um the way that people respond
to those kinds of claims even if I think
we think you know a little bit less
about the the sort of like ethical
disposition and and more just about the
sort of strategy at the very least
normally when campaigns are sort of
crafting advertisements we think they
have to have a theory about what people
value what moves them what they'll
respond to and that process of
understanding voters is I think a really
important Dimension that goes into
representation and so a kind of key
question is um you know how is
generative AI being used in conjunction
with that process and I think there
might be concerns about whether um you
know campaigns are able to craft
effective ads without actually sort of
having a an understanding of what it is
that makes them effective um and then
from the side of thinking about voters
or or the broader public I think you
know a lot of it it depends on sort of
what exact
um it you know generative AI might be
being used for of course there's reasons
to be concerned as noted about deceptive
or manipulative information regardless
of of where it comes from but I think
even beyond that we might think that um
you know uh voters are might be sort of
concerned or or alienated by um the idea
of campaigns using AI just the sense
that there's this kind of other layer of
technology and lexity that makes
politics seem opaque and like something
that can't really be sort of understood
or controlled and I think you know
there's obviously lots of complexity in
government more generally but I think
especially in elections these are
supposed to be occasions when people are
sort of feel uniquely empowered and and
have a kind of sense of ownership over
democracy and I think we should be
especially worried about uh the erosion
of that feeling in that context I think
that's such an important point and that
was something that we wrote quite a bit
about in the white paper but didn't
really expand on our presentation is
that we tend to think and and and Greg
was really the driving force of some of
the research behind this we tend to
think that the ability for these let's
say microt targeted AI created ads or
chat Bots to really like fool a large
number of people into changing how they
vote we think that's very unlikely like
given everything we know about how hard
it is to actually change voters Minds on
stuff given evidence that other things
like that targeted ads and the like have
not had big effects on people's
attitudes we we not saying there's no
issue there but we're we think that it's
probably a little bit overstated in the
in the magnitude of votes it could
change but the very perception that it
could have a big effect is like
problematic even if the true effect is
not very large and so that's one of the
things we're concerned about we have in
mind particularly like one risk where
some enterprising new company this is
basically I think guaranteed to happen
is going to claim we use this fancy new
technology and and they'll sell this to
campaigns to kind of get a bunch of new
people to vote for you who wouldn't have
before because we able to hack their
brains and so forth we think the
likelihood of those claims being true is
very low but that could get Amplified
through the media and through discussion
until people believe it's really true
and then they could question the very
kind of like fairness of the election as
a whole because of it so that's
something that's definitely on our mind
do you have any ideas on like things we
could do to kind of help restore
people's sense of like control over the
electoral process yeah I think in
general
um thinking about kind of ways that
communities can can sort
of um create more kind of like tangible
interactions between people and and the
kind of voting process to make it feel a
little bit more distant so this is less
about the um thinking about the
information environment specifically but
about sort of just like in general
thinking about offsetting ways um to
make people feel sort of a greater sense
of ownership so one thing that I think
is really important is creating more
um neighborhood polling places that
allows sort of more opportunities for
people to have kind of direct
interactions with um poll worker
volunteers I think that that kind of
sense of a a more of a face tof face as
well as a a kind of understanding of the
community kind of putting out resources
for voting is is really important um but
I think you can also think about kind of
trying to structure the deliberative
environment in a way that um allows
people to sort of feel like they have a
chance to really kind of reflect on
things so um in many countries uh there
are is actually an election silence uh
leading up to to election day or to the
period of voting uh where there's a a
kind of limitation on campaign
activities um and the idea is that it's
supposed to create this space for people
to kind of take a back uh take a step
back and kind of reflect on and and
think about um the the kind of messaging
that they they've received and and to be
able to kind of make a cooler reasoning
um for elections now in the United
States that would be um unconstitutional
um to have a kind of a government
regulation to that effect um but you
know individual platforms I think could
take it upon themselves to create a kind
of moratorium for days or weeks leading
up to the election to try and create um
an environment where people feel like
they're able to have that space to
evaluate things yeah it's a super
interesting idea I know there's some
precedent for it I don't remember the
exact details but in 2020 I think
Facebook um didn't allow new political
ads in the last like two weeks of the
election or something like that and I
think some other platforms have played
with with rules like that as well it's
super interesting uh okay Ethan let you
have the last word here I think there we
I had kind of flagged this more general
question about where the world is
heading with all this new technology and
whether we should worry about how the
kind of like overall control of the
information environment is going to look
in the future and and would just
appreciate any broad thoughts you have
on what is that world going to look like
and what kinds of steps do you think
would make sense to consider in advance
of it yeah so I don't I guess I'm going
to say more about what I think we don't
know and what we need to figure out um
but I do think I mean one of the reasons
I think we wanted to flag this is I
think
um people who are thinking about AI
regulation quite broadly not about AI in
elections in particular are thinking
about things like AI safety uh Ai and
the future of work uh and the like
and one of the things that many of I
think the most prominent proposals we
see out there things like licensing
requirements things like uh you know if
you're using x amount of compute you
have to jump through a bunch of extra
regulatory hurdles that if you're not
using that much compute you don't have
to many of I think the policy proposals
we've seen proposed by the tech
companies and taken up at least
deliberatively by by the Congress and
the administration um are likely to have
the effect effect of exacerbating Market
concentration uh and there's all sorts
of right we have lots of Frameworks
we're thinking about Market
concentration what's good and what's bad
about it and I think it one of the
things we wanted to do is just put on
the table here that politics is one of
the things that should be in part of
that conversation that it's not just
about Market competition and Market
power it's not just about replacement of
jobs or Etc but that that having a small
number of technology companies have
substantial control over the sources and
choices about our political speech is of
great consequence for society and it
shouldn't be out of the conversation
even though it is not in our usual way
of thinking about things like antitrust
um so and that's sort of the broad
framing of why we wanted to put this on
the table is I think lots of
conversations that are not about AI in
elections have real consequences for
politics so let me just say one other
thing about what I think we don't know
and I think the thing at least it feels
to me like we don't know is which
direction any of those any of those
effects go so um I feel like
um I'm old enough to remember lots of
different versions of the American
information environment it feels to me
like I feel like I remember a childhood
in which Walter kronite more or less uh
I mean I wasn't paying attention I just
wish that you know Gil's Island would
come on or something but uh it was to
like telling my parents what to think or
something um maybe some of you know my
father you can't tell him anything but
uh you know he was telling the americ
what to think and there was this highly
centralized it was this highly
centralized information environment
where we had a couple big newspapers we
did have a lot of diversity of local
newspapers but we had you know kind of
the big three networks and and a
news a news ecosystem that was highly
concentrated um and I think lots of
people look up back on that and think
like that was an age of reason and I
don't know um and and then things
started change we had first the Advent
of cable news where we had a lot more
choice and a lot more diversity of
information in ways that I think see
seemed really good from some
perspectives and also like maybe had
some pernicious effects and then we had
the growth of the internet and the what
I think of as in some sense The Glory
Days of Twitter where uh there stopped
in some sense being any Authority and we
all just had like you know even in the
age of of of cable news where we all had
lots of choice about what to watch none
of us had a voice like only a few people
had a voice right we got to make lots of
choices about what we heard but we
didn't get to speak very much other than
locally um and then Twitter came along
right or maybe Facebook before it and we
could all speak and like most people
weren't listening to most of us but
there was a chance that lots of people
would listen to some thing we said which
is upsetting um and that was a a whole
different a whole different information
environment of this kind of Citizen
opinion journalist or something I don't
know um and now it feels like that's
disappearing and we're getting back
towards concentration first we had
content moderation on top of that and
maybe that was good and maybe it was bad
it reconcentrated in some ways and also
it shut a lot of us up in some ways um
and now maybe we're going to have so so
which of those is like good for
democracy is a I think a very
complicated question about the role of
authority the role of Freedom where the
information resides and where it should
reside who should be deliberating on
what should I mean it's just a it's it's
it's a it's a stew and I think actually
the the answers there are not are not at
all obvious so I think we should be
sensitive to that I do think I think
that that you and I talked about that I
think is worth just highlighting here is
one difference between the the age of
concentration where you know open AI is
deciding uh making the big decisions
about political speech and the world in
which Walter kronite was making
decisions about political about what we
talked about about politics is that
Walter kronite or the New York Times or
whoever you want right were were you
know governed by a set of journalistic
norms um that had to do of course they
were businesses but also they had to do
with a whole set of profal norms about I
don't know some sort of notion of
balance some sort of notion of of
civic-mindedness and informing the
public at what whatever that you think
like Norms are really important in ways
that are hard to study and those are
different than the Norms of running a
technology company and so another thing
we want to want another dimension we
might want to think about here is not
just how centralized is control but like
where do we want if we're going to have
authority where do we want what kind of
entity do we want that authority to to
to reside in and what kind of norms
should they be governed by there's a lot
to unpack there maybe we'll get to in
some of the Q&A many more hours will
need to be spent on this okay let's open
it up to questions um okay maybe we'll
start over here on the uh yeah go
ahead start by saying what school you're
in Alum of the Harris School of Public
Policy uh yes um my name is Al gav I'm a
Staff engineer at the Chan Zuckerberg
Institute initiative rather um I'm
interested so uh Ethan you kind of
alluded to this that the media
environment um and the information
environment along round elections has
been problematic for years right and we
can even go back to like you know the
heurst media Empire um and his influence
over his own newspapers right um so I'm
curious you know as we kind of think
about moving forward monopolization and
sort of the the agglomeration of um
power within the market is something
that's going to happen it's already
happening um many of my peers working in
mlops are already you know mostly using
open AI um so I'm curious to what extent
is the policy problem a media lit
problem um and to what extent can we
actually rely on that as some sort of
antidote to some of the uh current
issues within our information
Department I I'll take a first stab at
that I'm curious there's think I'm a
little bit skeptical of media literacy
at least the way it's been framed so far
it seems to often be this like the easy
thing people point to um is and actually
unpacking how it would work I think is
is is very challenging I agree that one
way or another we need to get to a point
one of the first order of things we need
to fix is that people don't let's say
believe everything they see through one
of these Bots and so I think there are a
set of
Behavioral challenges that probably like
we've seen on social media younger
people will adapt to faster than older
people who are kind of used to previous
norms and stuff and so I think there's
something that has to be done there I
think a lot of the challenge I've at
least seen in the media literacy world
has just been figuring out like how do
you actually do that and I think there's
people some of people on campus here
actually studying that in really
interesting ways but I don't know it
seems like we're a ways from actually
being able to implement like some kind
of program of media literacy that
wouldn't seem highly partisan or or
otherwise like kind of
compromised yeah I think there's there's
also like a risk of these these programs
like um the one I'm thinking of is like
training people how to recognize fake
news that makes them better at being
able to detect fake news but it also
just makes them distrust everything
because they think they're like uh like
the Poss possibility of fake news is
sort of highlighted to them so there is
this like bad negative consequence on
stuff that and like most things are not
fake news so like the net effect of that
program might not actually be good um
and so we have I think we have to think
carefully before we want to roll out
something like that on a broad scale
yeah one thing I would just add to that
I think is is underneath what you're
saying I think is really important is
like there's just something about the
Bots work right now especially chat gvt
but they all kind of it's just like it's
so confident and it just makes you think
it's right and I've had it like design
um syllabuses for my class when you
first read them they look amazing and
I'm like I can't believe I hadn't read
this I didn't know that Greg and Matt
jensco wrote a paper together and it
turns out it's all made up and so there
is like a media literacy issue that's
front and center with just there's
something about the user experience
today with these tools that leads at
least in my experience to a lot of
overconfidence and so I I do think it it
is like a
behavioral problem that that we need to
work on
yeah so we can we can work around the
room
yeah
thank you my name is sham yazaki and I'm
a GSP predock under working under
Professor Andy Hol so it's very exciting
to see the panel is ranging from
normative political philosopher to
empirical um policy research that's why
I would like to ask the following
question us do do us or US companies
have to be responsible for the misuse or
malfunctions of the the AI technology in
the foreign countries given the most us
companies are creating uh most AI
companies are from us but foreign
countries like Europe Asian African any
other countries can use
it yeah Andy what's the answer I mean I
would just say I think you're
highlighting what's been a big concern
for a long time that really started in
social media when content moderation
became an important issue in social
media it and and when AI started being
used to help with that uh I think one of
the most immediate problems was and this
probably I'm something Christian
probably can speak to a lot more
authoritatively than me is like we get
these biases that come from it being
trained largely on English language
largely from the US and we've seen lots
of challenges with when it gets applied
to other countries in other languages
where cultural norms or expectations are
different where people communicate in
different ways so yeah I would expect
that to be a big a big challenge moving
forward yeah I I can just sort of back
up what you're saying I think you know a
lot of what we see is that the models do
end up get trained mostly on English
language data not in entirely of course
and you can see differences in
performance across language um which
could maybe make it difficult to assess
some of the issues you're talking about
but absolutely I think in an Ideal World
of course the companies would pay
attention to what's going on all over
the world with these sorts of things I
suspect the uh resources to do that are
not there right now um so I wouldn't
expect that it's actually happening but
that I I'm not in a company more I don't
know that's just a prediction from how
I've seen that things
work
hi Josh glonk I'm a visiting scholar at
seesac here at Stanford also a haris
Alum U my questions for Christian you
talked about one of the forms of biases
potentially being if I go to a chat bot
and I say tell me some more about a
particular issue I might give me a
biased sort of set of sources from that
wondering how much different is that
from the tools we use today if I go to a
search engine on the internet and ask
about an issue is it somehow giving me
more representative sample and the
second part of this question is when you
talk to the industry about these biases
kind of what is your sense of their
position I'm sure stated you know they
would all say yeah bias is bad we don't
uh we we want to prevent it however it
would seem to me there's a bit of a
conflict of interest between what we
would think is sort of right from a
public policy standpoint of providing
voters with representative sort of uh
samples of information so they can make
an informed decision in the business
aspect of it which would be as Gregory
you said people trust and they like to
go to the sources that are ex agree with
their pre-existing beliefs from a
business standpoint I probably want to
keep feeding people
those sources they like to read because
that's going to keep them on my platform
so what's your sense of how interested
the industry really is in purveying bias
yeah I mean I think that's a great
question and honestly I think you framed
it exactly right I think it is largely
the same issue as what you see in search
when we're talking about you know asking
for a recommendation for different types
of content it really is that's the sort
of strange things about these models is
they can sort of work as recommendation
systems they can sort of work as
predictive models they can work as
content generation um and so I guess
what what I think about that is that I
do think in the context of search people
have thought a bit more about this I'm
sure the companies are thinking about
this now I think there's a little less
transparency on in terms of what they're
doing about it um but I I think it is
really almost exactly the same issue
which you've highlighted can I point out
I think this is one of these areas where
there's real questions about Market
concentration versus Market uh
unconcentrated competition um that the
world of lots of competition is a world
in some sense like cable news where
maybe you're letting people select you
know they're you're letting people
select into the algorithm that suits
them um and the world of Market
concentration is the one in which you
know one or two companies are making
important content moderation decisions
about about what the Baseline of Truth
is or whatever what what's the unbiased
thing um
and one of the worries I think that
people have had say about social media
is that we've been in that market
concentration world and and those social
media companies have been making strong
content moderation decisions in the ways
that they do Al algorithmic
amplification Etc um that are shaping
our political discourse people of course
also worry about the world in which
everybody enters their Echo chamber so a
world in which we have a ton of
competition and you get to choose your
bias is a world where we're in that Echo
chamber kind of worry as opposed to the
world in which where the tech executive
is choosing what we get to think and
those are both there's trade-offs
there
thanks good panel uh John scull I'm an
instructor here at GSP uh when you talk
about Market
concentration we also have Market
concentration in government and so given
that you basically have a duopoly so how
might AI change that Dynamic
either allow us to be not as divisive
but possibly bring together or or bring
up and strengthen the voices of third
parties or or other entities that
previously just can't break through the
duopoly that exists just be curious your
sense of
that I feel like gre's GNA say yeah I
mean I think I think it's unlikely to
change like there's sort of structural
forces about us politics that make two
the two-party system pretty stable and I
think AI is not going to change those so
I wouldn't expect AI to lead to some the
emergence of some new thir uh third
party that's going to be successful
electorally um yeah I was at that at
that level I wouldn't expect I don't
know if you guys have thoughts I was
hoping maybe you would say something
about uh underfunded Challengers and the
like electoral competitiveness within
the two- party system yes okay so that
this did come up in the in the white
paper a bit I think that is one possible
like probably good effect of AI is that
you know it is a fairly big barrier to
entry like if you want to run a campaign
just hiring a professional campaign
manager is quite expensive and uh many
candidates don't have the resources to
be able to do that if AI can substitute
for that if you know you don't have to
hire an advertising firm instead you can
get trat gbd to do it that might open up
the you make it possible for lots of
candidates to enter who wouldn't have
been able to otherwise that might make
you know reduce the barriers to running
uh running for office which might make
the system more competitive which would
think would be good but I think the
likelihood that that they're going to
form a third party is is pretty
low my question is in a discussion on AI
and democracy the one thing that none of
you mentioned today is how AI um might
be used as a tool for some actors to
incite violence and undermine the Norms
of democratic systems and institutions
and you did all talk about the ability
or the lower likelihood of AI to be used
on an individually targeted basis but
I'm thinking what is the likelihood that
AI will be used for those um sort of
Tipping Point demographics that might
not have been incited to violence
previously but could now be targeted in
a way that makes a larger concentration
of folks want to say another January
6th I have some quick thoughts on that
we be curious with other thing too I
mean I so one thing that is noticeable
about usage patterns of AI so far if you
look um there's some websites where you
can this comes back to the transparency
issu we can't learn a lot but there are
these websites that at least purport to
tell you how many hours users are using
these different service and one of the
things that's striking is actually these
services that create these personality
chat Bots have the by by far the most
hours per user and and if you look for
example at issues that open AI has
flagged publicly is the policy issues
they think are most important for them
to get public input on it's problematic
use of the chatbot people using it for
too many hours and it kind of goes to a
demographic that I think you might be
talking about which is like a set of
very lonely isolated people forming
perhaps like kind of worrying personal
relationships with a chatbot and that
does seem like an area where you could
worry about that then veering into
various kinds of problematic behavior
and so I do think it's an area that
people are worrying about it's it's
probably less expert for this panel but
I do think it's an issue I'd say at a
higher level we did think a little bit
in the white paper about how you might
use these tools either to suppress
people's political Behavior or to incite
other kinds of political behavior and
and one thing we kind of thought was um
there's sort of two mechanis is Ms one
is the one I was just talking about
which is the radicalization of
individual people the other is like the
sharing of content that encourages that
kind of behavior publicly and so I think
the first one we I just talked about is
like that's an ongoing issue um that
probably has to be solved at the level
of like how how many hours are people
allowed to use these services and so
forth this the higher level issue I
think what we concluded is that there's
really not very much new here like it
probably makes it easier for someone to
make that that content that encourages
you know people to show up here or do
that this but really the harm still
comes at the level of the distribution
of that content at scale and so it
really kind of collapses back in our
view I think to a somewhat standard
content moderation problem that's not to
say that content moderation has been
solved by any means but it's not the Gen
makes it a little bit easier to make
that content but it doesn't really do
anything in and of itself to help you
distribute it farther than you could
before yeah yeah maybe I'll just add
that um if you're thinking about
Democratic Norms more generally so maybe
kind of broadening out from this kind of
like specific radicalization but just
thinking about how do you support uh
Norms like most especially if it's sort
of informal Norms of like you know how
do we engage with each other in a kind
of way that that's civil and that
supports a kind of healthy Democratic
relationships um we get a sense of what
the Norms are just from like statistical
observation of other people's behavior
um and that includes you know both in
person but also like things that we we
sort of read or or see and so I think
there's just a sort of question about
like the the sort of sheer quantity of
information that's out there and how
does that sort of shape our perception
of like what is kind of normal speech so
if you have a lot of bots producing um
uh you know Norm violating speech or
something then then you might worry that
that leads to a distorted view about
like whether these Norms are generally
enforced in society and people are going
to be more likely to violate Norms if
they think that other people just don't
treat them seriously either I'll say one
of I spent a lot of my career working on
terrorism and counterterrorism so I was
think about it from that perspective a
little bit um I guess I was say a few
things I want us to be careful about in
this this this conversation so one is um
lots of forms of political violence are
actually very social activities so
January 6 is a very social activity um
most of important forms of terrorism are
very social activities they're not the I
mean you know there's the kind of Lone
Wolf unibomber kind of story um but
that's not the story of most political
violence um that's thing one thing
two it political violence is this
incredibly rare thing not rare in the
sense that there's lots of political
violence in the world but a person
becoming radicalized it's an incredibly
rare thing and therefore extremely
difficult to study what if anything we
know about what leads to it and so we
tend to observe people like the
Unabomber who had this very isolated we
think oh well that's but of course there
were a million isolated people who had
no whatever who just lived their and so
I think we have to be careful about that
too because I think the the the other
part of the story is like the
999,000 who were maybe using the chatbot
and they were Lely people having a more
meaningful life with the chatbot than
they were without so I just wanted like
like like mobilization for political
violence is super hard thing to to
understand and we we actually we don't
know a ton about it because it's just
this rare phenomenon that's hard to
study and there are trade-offs there
this is from an mppm from Harris how can
lowbudget campaigns get the most out of
AI to make greater impact and come up
with better policy
proposals so I don't know I have any
like specific uh things that that they
should be include any messages that they
should be including in uh in ads but I
do think it's a really you know it's a
really valuable tool that because it's
much less expensive than like hiring a
political consulting firm uh who tend to
be very expensive um it does open up the
possibility of making professional ads
too much like a broader set of people
who maybe aren't super connected to the
party establishment in in the way that
came up earlier so that's um yeah I
don't know have I'm not like a
practitioner so I I don't know that I
have any like practical advice about how
to craft really great uh really great
ads but I do think there's a lot of
potential to use it to use it for that
purpose okay I think we are at time I
know some people were waiting I'm happy
to stay around after I'm sure others are
as well we'd love to continue the
conversation y thank you everyone Thanks
for
[Music]